on the count of three look right into
here and do not blink okay
[Music]
high fives and low fives are better than
no fives
if somebody calls you a wet blanket ask
them how they'd like it in a
desert if they saw you there are you
getting this yes yes
more more if you step on a berry you
just made some jam
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
tenders hush and lovers dove
by daytime
[Music]
i miss this jinx
[Music]
oh my god
there's a room full of just guns why do
you have so many guns
this is america isn't it yes then i
don't have to answer stupid questions
while standing on my own property
let's go okay well that's definitely
ron's mom
don't try to freak out my friend so you
can sell some t-shirts
because she's not gonna freak out
she's not gonna be like shut it down
clown town order in the sport court
time of death uh now simon says
you gotta go to the bus station and get
far away
from here richard nixon
okay you don't get to decide
whether we're gonna sing new stuff or
old stuff because
unlike you xander we
have stuff if this is what pete needs
i would be willing to welcome you into
our lovemaking
no as no pete i know that i haven't been
very sexual since my mother died no stop
paula stop
you know you really got to service these
things every three months this thing is
shot
see ya wouldn't want to be in
i don't know how this could have
happened i even put post-its up on my
never forgets board
oh no oh crap they fell behind the
copier
oops water plant
is this salve also handmade that's
actually foot made
ha and did uh
one pair of feet make it or two
just one do you not date anyone
or you're dating somebody with no feet
or you're dating someone with feet that
doesn't want to help you with your stand
and i mean i don't know why they would
not be supportive of you
i mean unless i'm not dating anyone
delightful
i'll take the salve then how's
cornell treating you oh i left adjunct
paint was garbage
i'm at columbia now really so you're
back
you're back in the city huh yeah three
days a week
give you a big discount thank you
[Music]
looks like i'm done for the day he
cleaned me out oh
cool cool
yeah i'm probably just gonna go admire
the artistry of
a spider's web or whatevs
do you wanna hang out yes sorry that was
a combination of yep and let's but you
know what i meant right
oh well good morning beautiful songbird
you sound just like the loon that
visited our lake house oh yeah he died
last summer we're pretty sure that a
power line got him we found like a
basket of
ribs like a chard helen helen helen
so get this i'm finally leaving toledo
yeah i'm free
what you've only been here three little
months yeah i know
oh i once took a nap longer than that
of course i had just slammed into the
straight side of a
water ski ramp uh-huh my eyes were open
i was talking but
i was dead as i was saying um yeah i'm
i'm out of here i'm gonna go head the
stanford philosophy department
hey not too shabby
yeah i'd say you're going to greener
pastures but california is on fire
okay hey when you leave could i please
have that big fancy professor throne
professor oh my my massage chair yes
yeah sure why not yeah you could you
could really stand to uh
relax oh thank you oh he's such a cutie
and i don't lie about that i'll call a
pig a pig
[Music]
you